To answer this question, I'll start with some of the code that I was using in
the hint videos. Here's the homework scores class. And so far, it's keeping
track of a sum and a number of scores. This code returns a sum but doesn't
actually think about excluding the lowest. The way I see this problem, there
are two key insights. The first is that to return the total excluding the
lowest. We don't necessarily need to permanently remove the low score. If we
can find the low score, we can return the total minus the low score, just
subtract it off at the last moment. The second insight is that we don't need to
save all of the scores to know what the lowest score is. We only need to save
the value of the lowest scores itself, so instead of a method that finds the
lowest score I will create an instances variable to track the lowest score so
far, I will define it as private double lowest which probably make these
private to, now I am going to need some special cases in my
getTotalExcludingLowest because if the number of scores is zero, I want to
return zero, but if the number of scores is one, I want to return that one
score which is currently the sum. And if there are more then I want to return
the sum without the lowest score. To keep track of how many scores there are,
I'm using the counting pattern. I start with the number of scores being zero
and when I add a score, I increment the number of scores by one. Now, for this
new variable, lowest score. Or lowest, as I'm calling it. I need to come up
with an initial value. Ideally I would initialize it with the first score. But
I don't know what that is yet in the constructor. So I'll initialize it with
minus one, and promise never to look at it until I've added at least one score.
This is a good example of why you want to keep your instance variables private.
People using the homework scores class might not realize that lowest isn't
always initialized. Only the homework scores class knows about this
implementation detail. And when you mark this as private, it shows that the
homework scores objects are responsible for interpreting the data inside of the
lowest score variable. So outsiders don't need to remember things like, I
shouldn't look at the lowest score until I've added scores. So now I've
initialized the lowest score, but I need to think about how it's changing. I'll
need to make sure that in add score, when there aren't any scores yet, I should
initialize lowest to be the given score. Then I need to think about, what
happens when I add additional scores. The lowest score seen so far can change
whenever I add a score. This is a lot like looking for the minimum score in a
loop. When I see a new score, if the score is less than the lowest so far, I
update the lowest to be score, now it looks like under both of these conditions
numScores is zero or the score is less than the lowest, I change the lowest to
be the score, so let's make this into one if statement, if num score is zero or
score is less than lowest, then lowest equal score making get rid of this
repetition and then these two statements happen no matter what whenever I see a
new score I count that I've seen another score and I add the score to the sum.
So now if I compile and fix my syntax errors, I can run the homework scores
tester. And the homework scores class behaves as it should.